hello and welcome back to 8701 so in
this class you want to talk about
the range of forces and specifically how
the range of forces depend on the mass
of the particle involved
in transmitting the force we have seen
this table before you know that the
different forces the strong force the
electromagnetic force
and the weak force and the boson
which carries carries the force
on gluons photons in the w and the z
bowser
but now we want to actually just look
into the aspect of
of the range and how mass is interplay
here
so you all know the electromagnetic
potential usual point charge given by
the maximum equation
we have seen this equation before
and the time independent potential here
you also know that the massless proton
gives rise to an infinite range of the
electromagnetic interaction
but the question now is how would this
change how would this be modified
if the photon were massive
so to do this
we have to generalize this a little bit
first of all we have to look at the
time dependent equation or the wave
equation
this is wave equation
we have also seen this before
wave equation
and by adding a mass term so we are
using here
an equation um which has to be fulfilled
by all particles
um it's a relation between energy
momentum and mass
the uh we have discussed this in the
context of special relativity
before what we are trying to do now is
build a
schrodinger-like equation by using the
quantum mechanical operators
for energy and momentum so we just add
this here
and find a new equation which is called
the klein gordon equation
that's equation
so this equation has to be in all
particle waves
or particles have to fulfill this
equation
um so the question is you know what kind
of solutions
does this kind of equation have how does
this look like
and if you now you know start from
again a time independent equation
you find solutions which look like this
right and you see again very similar
than to before the charge over some
constant as a function of radius
but you also see this exponential term
and what we see here is this potential
this form of potential is called you
cover potential
and what's nicely shown in this plot
here is again
the potential as a function of radius in
units of
femtometers the dependency of the mass
on the
of the range of the force on the mass so
you see here as an example for the mass
equal to zero
mark mass equal to one jv and mass equal
to 10gb and you can easily see
the range of the force is reduced by the
fact that
the particle actually had mass now
the gauge both on the both end of the
weak interaction the w and the z
position are quite massive
they have masses in the order of 80 90
or the order of 100 geb
so you can see that the masses actually
leads to reduction of the strength of
the of the range of this force
and we find you just not look
don't look at the gravitational part
here it's not
part of the standard model if you look
at electromagnetic interaction where the
range is
infinite we find that the range of the
weak interaction is 10 to the minus 18
meters so this is greatly reduced
because of the masses of the particle if
we just look at the
you know charge itself we would find
that the weak interaction and the
electromagnetic interaction are actually
quite comparable
we will also talk about the strong
interaction this year here
there's a strong interaction that the
coupling
and alpha is in the order one so when we
talked about finding diagrams we talked
about perturbation theory
now if you do a perturbation series for
a interaction of cup of order of one
couplings of order one your vertices in
the other one
you'll see that perturbation theory
might break down
so okay so what we have seen in this
lecture um
is how a mass or how masses um
reduce the range of a force uh we have
simply built
klein gordon equation here
looked at a solution and found that
there is this diminishing
of um the range of the force
later um we will look at one additional
complication and another equation which
has been
hit by particles which is so-called
direct equation which has to be
fulfilled
or hold up by by fermions
but that's beyond of the scope of this
of this club we'll look at this later in
more detail
you